nos vamos a perú ántero flores-aráoz a
asumir el cargo de primer ministro un
día después de que manuel merino asumirá
la presidencia del país tras la
destitución de martín vizcarra en medio
de denuncias de corrupción en el
congreso la juramentación desató
protestas y enfrentamientos en las
calles del 1 es por ello que enlazamos
con juan jiménez mayor ex jefe del
gabinete ministerial y ex ministro de
justicia de perú gracias por esta
comunicación señor jiménez mayor
flores-aráoz aún no revela quiénes
integrarían su gabinete de ministros que
se espera de los integrantes y del nuevo
gabinete ex ministro
bueno se espera que regresemos a la
normalidad estamos desde el día lunes en
el país prácticamente sin gobierno los
ministros del presidente de vizcarra
renunciaron en la noche del lunes y al
día siguiente se aceptaban todas las
renuncias y de otra manera que se fueron
a su casa en este momento lo que es
incomprensible por parte de las
autoridades peruanas es que no tengamos
un consejo de ministro que ya esté
tomando decisiones porque estamos en
medio de una situación muy dramática en
el país con un problema sanitario de la
pandemia ustedes sabrán que somos como
los países más golpeados en el mundo y
por supuesto la crisis económica y
social que estamos atravesando no
podemos darnos el lujo de tener un
desgobierno como el que tenemos en este
momento en el país y por supuesto encima
de todo esto marchas que están generando
por supuesto mucha expectativa en la
población y en la opinión pública sobre
lo que va a pasar en los próximos días
en el curvón mañana se ha convocado una
marcha que se espera que sea
multitudinaria y creo que esto es muy
grave para el país señor jiménez mayor
como usted nos identifica
hay crisis política sanitaria y
económica que debe priorizar el primer
ministro del nuevo gobierno para superar
los retos en perú
sin duda la crisis sanitaria estamos
experimente una curva descendente pero
estamos esperando en el país
probablemente una segunda ola como ha
sucedido en europa esperamos que esto no
ocurra bien y en el tema económico el
país ha sufrido un impacto tremendo la
cepal pronosticó hasta cierre de año una
caída en américa latina' del 9% sin
embargo el perú ya con datos del banco
central tiene una caída a diciembre de
este año de más del 12% la inversión
pública en el país en este momento a
noviembre del año 2020 está apenas en
36% lo que deja una brecha tremenda y
desafortunadamente el gobierno no sea
realmente actual sino el gobierno del
presidente vizcarra no dio las salidas
adecuadas para poder generar una
inversión pública que pueda sacarnos de
la crisis entonces estamos en una
situación muy complicada y al
informalmente a esto un proceso
electoral y por comenzar a dimitir ha
comenzado en el país y que entendemos
entendemos en abril del próximo año
ministro qué opinión le merece ántero
flores-aráoz y manuel merino brevemente
nos quedan unos segunditos bueno que
creo que no es muy ambicioso lo que está
pasando en el país se está polarizando
el perú políticamente nuevamente ya no
es una organización entre los poderes
del estado sino es una polarización de
la calle y el gobierno y creo que va a
ser muy difícil para el gobierno que
pueda remontar un escenario digamos de
popularidad youtube como tuvo el
presidente de vizcarra y creo además que
la situación no la tienen todas consigo
porque los mensajes que se está dando el
gobierno con las designaciones creo que
no son lo mejor ya ha comenzado una
masiva renuncia de funcionarios del
gobierno y esto creo que no le hace bien
a la democracia porque vamos a tener
muchas semanas muchos meses
probablemente también de de gobierno y
de situaciones de gestión bastante bajas
en el país juan jiménez mayor muchas
gracias por esta comunicación